les escargots stars de notre 3e épisode
consacrés à la Semaine du Goût oui mais
pas n'importe lesquels ceux-là sont
élevés dans l'un des 350 élevages que
contre l'hexagon et plus précisément en
Loir et Cher créé en 2019 l'entreprise
les escargots du château élève et
transforme des escargot appelés gros
gris ils seront sans doute sur nos
tables de Noël voyez ce reportage de
Clémence d'sque avec Benjamin Vattel
c'est notre rubrique savourons le Val-de
Loire à l'abri de la lumière et protégé
des prédateurs par un filet 250000
occupants quelque peu endormis
grandissent etciculteur huglerou élève
des escargots gros gris un marché de
niche se prétend plutôt bien aux
conditions climatique boss Ron j'ai fait
le choix de faire ce système de planche
il y en a qui vont faire uniquement dans
l'herbes il y en a qui vont faire des
planche plus basse moi c'est parce que
je trouvais ça pratique pour distribuer
l'aliment pour RAM ass c'est à hauteur
d'homme l'éliciculteur se fourn chez un
autre éleveur dans le Loiré qui assure
la reproduction des gastéropodes à leur
arrivé dans le parc il mesure moins d'un
cmtre nourri d'un mélange composé entre
autres de poids de maïs ou encore de
calcium pour renforcer leurs coquilles
ils atteignent leur taille adulte au
bout de 5 mois donc moi je reçois des
bumé avant ça ils ont quand ils arrivent
ils ont 15 jours 3 semaines à peu près
et à partir de mi-septembre je vais
pouvoir commencer à ramasser les
premiers et le ramassage il va
s'effectuer jusqu'à mi-nvembre passionné
de cuisine HUG fournit plusieurs
restaurateur Loiré chérien il fait aussi
découvrir ses produits en apéritif pour
attirer la clientèle gofret préfou ou
samousa le secret réside dans
l'assaisonnement l'escargot est
moelleux on a bien le goût de l'escargot
et derrière ce petit côté periller a que
qui qui reste en bouche si l'éleveur
réalise près de 40 % de son chiffre
d'affaires aux alentours de Noël il
assure que les escargots peuvent être
dégustés tout au long de
l'année